uh I just saw you I didn't know you had
a daughter until I saw the video you
just posted yes I mean I didn't even
send you the album by accident so I
didn't send the ultrasound no so uh how
old is your daughter
a little over three months well
congratulations thank you has that
changed your life drastically I mean
obviously besides like waking up but has
it like some people I mean listen I have
a son that's 18 I had him when I was
well he's about to be 18. I had him when
I was 18. so I had him when I was 18.
but that you know it was so long ago I
couldn't like I just was like trying not
to be poor and be homeless you know
understandable so like I don't know like
like what did that what does that do for
you like mentally
um it's weird I used to look at like
parents when they would say like
memeable
like corny basic [__] about kids I'm
like all right I'm sure it's that way
yeah I get it but I it makes me stop it
like reminds me of Joy just like just
looking at her makes me stop where I
never would have stopped like that's the
surface level of how it's changed my
life it's like little moments
I lacked little moments in my life until
her of course she's the biggest moment
but just watched a little moment created
little moments in my life that I never
had before and like makes me re-observe
everything like I sound like the corny
parent now that I'm saying like I'm I'm
walking her in a stroller looking at her
and she's looking up at trees and I'm
like [__] just she's amazing remember
trees remember those
and she is just amazed by [__] so I
don't know if it's selfish to say this
but it also has allowed me to like be
reintroduced to so much things within
these three months of watching her
observe other [__] that I've had around
me forever right like it makes me even
appreciate
[__] a bit more like just her curiosity
of everything makes me feel weird do you
feel like because I always say to myself
I'm like okay I go to New York City like
when I go to New York
I'm always like I like it and I could
never [__] live here this is [__]
insane like I say the same thing about
other really yeah
yeah so I go to New York and I'm like
everyone's rubbing on each other
everyone I mean I appreciate everyone's
on the [__] grind they're going to
work they're [__] just you know
mission to wherever they gotta go but
I'm always like I could never like I'm
I'm sure raising a kid in New York
you're raising a strong [__] kid no
matter what because they got to deal
with [__] that nobody else in the US
really has to deal with in terms of just
going to school yeah for sure going to
the grocery store or whatever would you
public transportation
with a
man having more Woman daughter are you
like we might need to get like out the
city a little bit I mean it's such a
different New York than the one I know
um like she would be raised in a way way
different New York but yes it has
crossed my mind and my
entirely I was never going to leave New
York New Jersey Jersey was as far as you
know I just bought a crib in Jersey
that's as far as I was going to venture
off right I it's changed within these
three months you're like huh maybe
Atlanta's not so bad and it was it was
funny let me uh name drop pardon if I if
I drop the name uh I was talking with Al
Branch when we went down shout out to my
guy out we went down to Atlanta to shoot
some stuff I think for bet and we used
his studio um him and says the studio
and he was telling me he's like I was in
Queens my whole life like I never wanted
to leave I was never going to leave even
when the music industry started to leave
New York I was holding strong
and he said
my daughters no I had I had to get out
like the schools are better here I love
being able to just go pick them up drive
off like they're around fresh air all
the time like they can just explore like
it's just it's just a different
perspective and I feel them on that I I
think it could happen La no because I
think La is just the same as New York
just with palm trees well there's the
valley and valleys the Valley's nice
well I I was always [__] on
La not La the city
La the transplant La not la oh yeah
transplant L.A so obnoxious but that's
where if I were to move to LA at that
time would I would have been around
transference sure then I got to know a
lot of people that grew up in La grew up
in the valley and I saw a whole nother
side of it where I was like okay I
understand why people think this is the
greatest city in the world not a place
that I would move or bring my kid but
I have eased up on La I've explored
around and really got to know I was in
West Hollywood for like five years I
would just come land work and if you're
only in West Hollywood you're like this
is like there's Billboards everywhere
there's my safe haven was Saddle Ranch
like that's all that's why trashy for
sure I mean look at me don't let the my
parents I'm like traffic my parents are
coming to LA and they're like we gotta
go somewhere I'm assuming just assuming
I'm stereotyping my own parents it'd be
like that sound ranch place they got a
boom in there
let's check that out you know I was with
jelly roll at Saddle Ranch like a year
ago like singing Carrie country karaoke
oh we brought the whole team there for
our last La show and
edin wrote The Bull Demarest rode the
bull everyone rode the bull yeah there's
other areas yeah you know and then
obviously downtown's a [__] wild
Place [__] uh reason brought me around
like it's Carson area yeah recently
outro on the album right yes uh that we
produce with bank and um one of my
favorite producers Legend Coleman who
um did the intro on Kohl's 85 South oh
he did okay I think that's the right
name right 95 north 95 North shout out
to 85 South that's the one with Cameron
on it right yes 95 North great song um
Coleman produced Apple boy wonder he's
to me one of the
probably the most talented new producer
that I think everyone is going to really
gravitate to soon even when Bank started
on I sent it over to Coleman to help us
out with like keys and other stuff and
Bank was like yo can I sign him like who
this kid is incredible right
um so yeah Bank Coleman reason sobering
thoughts on the Mind John it actually
came from a conversation reason I had
when he was dropping me off at the
Mondrian and we sat in the car and
talked for like an hour and a half great
guy and I was like oh one of the best I
was like this we had another song called
reasonable ending which I think might be
licked on YouTube at this point people
that heard it and I said we got to redo
this like let's let's get a whole new
beat let's start this conversation we
just had needs to be the outro
um and Drake actually DM me and said
with a drake ass title like that there
better be bars on it
I don't think we disappointed
I think reason went crazy on the ship
um but yeah you reply and say next album
I got something for you no no because I
wouldn't play myself in that regard I
just don't think that's how
Drake features work
traffic he's a nice guy super nice guy
he owes me a lot of money but he's a
nice guy oh yeah don't you guys have
some bet he owes me money fifty thousand
dollars
yeah he'll never pay it because I don't
strike Drake as the guy to remember our
conversations me him Freddie Gibbs and
this guy at a bar
well he has a he has steak now he can't
give you like a voucher for 50 Grand
[__] sweet so you could bet your own
if I could lose it yeah you just got to
go to Turks Doc Rivers [__] ass cause
I'm sure he'll my luck he'll be the next
[__] coach and I want to kill myself
Drake isn't Low by staying in Turks I
know it's a beautiful island does he
live in Turks
it appears that way and I'm just gonna
go for tax reasons but that's just me
dude he bets like a million a day and
I'm like you can't do that and my thing
you can't do that in New York listen my
thing with the steak thing you have to
do that in in Turk so listen especially
for sure for sure my thing with steak is
why is everyone on stake that I see
betting like astronomical like the milk
boys and Drake and I'm like are they
giving them this [__] money
um I mean it could work in
a strip club type of way
because a lot of times like if you know
rappers will be booked for a strip club
and they will give them a certain amount
give them once here but you have to
throw these like it'll go back to the
club go back to the club it's for Optics
so I could definitely see a world where
steak would give popular people a crazy
credit where you're not gonna win and
you're not gonna pull this out but you
could bet you could bet it all lose
you'll be fine yeah but if you win
you're not gonna get the money I could
see that that's good PR especially with
with the betting world now that's the
new face Jay-Z's trying to put Caesars
in Times Square